School
s
I honestly don't know what I'm going to
do until I enjoy watching it afterwards
so what I done was I thought my
technique
so now I'm thinking you know I'll mess
that up tonight so as soon as I thought
I was having this I get it wrong
when I'm free flowering I'm okay
George also said in this conversation we
had in the bait you've got to be good
enough before you can do it
and at the moment I'm still on the
technically said
so you can stay on the technical for
many years
are you offer them something they take
it
and take it
so what we'll do is we'll do chandouchi
where I initiate and take it
I'll take it
so what am I doing
eye engine
but just a little bit
so I'm not just doing showing to you
kind of gosh
you pushed me
then the distance will be wrong
if I go in and make the distance I need
so I'm going to make the distance I need
and I'm here come on I'm winning I'm
winning number
it doesn't work
it's hard lately
subscribe
you get
I'm having to force myself
find the connection
if you're too tired to do that
please help
I'm going to be too deep if I go with
this
it's gonna go past me
I can adjust it back there
for the speed I wanted to go
I'm Gonna Be Too Deep I'm going to
adjust it here
we'll be too deep
I'm going to Castle
didn't move anywhere
and Too Deep
I've got weight on the back leg I can't
adjust it
don't be too late if I try and adjust it
when it gets lighter because I'm going
this way
I'm going to adjust it
in my belly
here too deep
I'm going to adjust it
you know I'd like it works
if you can make sense of that you're
back with me
anytime
work out
the distance
all right
the leg takes the body
the leg's got too much weight on it
push this back
I want you to find out where you're over
commitment is sometimes even as they
come to you you'll find that
for your clothes here
float
that I'd like you to watch the back leg
and the thumb
we are putting them together
float
okay